So, how did you do on your first absolute value inequality? Did you get negative
7 to 9? If so, great work. Let's see how we got that answer. When I see an
absolute value with a less than, I know that we're going to have an
intersection, which is going to leave us one region. To solve this absolute
value inequality, I can set it up as a compound inequality. Negative 2 is less
than or equal to x minus 1 over 4, which is less than or equal to 2. So, here's
our two cases. We have negative 2 is less than or equal to x minus 1 over 4 and
we have x minus 1 over 4 is less than or equal to 2. We can solve this compound
inequality all at one time. First thing I want to do is clear my fraction. To
clear my fraction, I'm going to multiply through by the least common denominator
which is 4. When I multiply through by 4, I have to multiply 4 by negative 2
which gives me negative 8. And I multiply 4 by x minus 1 over 4, which gives me
x minus 1. And I have to multiply 4 times 2, which is 8. The next thing I need
to do is isolate the x in the middle, so I have to add 1 to all three parts, and
I get negative 7 is less than or equal to x, which is less than or equal to 9.
And I can draw this on a number line. If this is 0 and this is 9 and this is
negative 7, we know that x has to be greater than or equal to negative 7 and x
has to be less than or equal to 9. So, I fill in the region in the middle. And
that gives me the interval from negative 7 to 9 with closed brackets. Remember,
we use closed brackets when we have less than or equal to or greater than or
equal to. Let's try another one.